[موسيقى]
من حلقات المواجهه بين اسرائيل وايران
تقديم نتنياهو عام 2018 ما قال انها نسخ
طبق الاصل من وثائق حصلت عليها المخابرات
الاسرائيليه من مخزن سري في طهران تتضمن
الف الادله المتعلقه بمشروع عماد لانتاج
خمس رؤوس النوويه وضمن ما يعرف بحرب السفن
تعرضت حامله مركبه تجاريه مملوكه لاسرائيل
لهجوم في 2020 بالقرب من ميناء الفجيره
بعد يوم من اتهام ايران لاسرائيل
بالمسؤوليه عن انفجار في منشاتنا النوويه
تستمر حروب الظل في البحر ففي 2001 اتهمت
اسرائيل ايران بمهاجمه ناقله تشغلها شركه
مملوكه للرجل اعمال اسرائيلي وذلك بطائره
مسيره ايرانيه في المحيط الهندي لكن طهران
نفذ ذلك تقارير غربيه كشفت ان اسرائيل
ايضا استهدفت
10 ناقله ايرانيه او تحمل نفطا ايرانيا
متجهه الى يا خلال السنتين الماضيتين
مسار اخر تعلق بالاغتيالات ففي نوفمبر
تشرين الثاني من عام 2020 اغتل مساعد وزير
الدفاع الايراني والعالم النووي محسن فخري
زاد قرب طهران واتهمت ايران اسرائيل
بالوقوف وراء الاغتيال وفي فبراير شباط
2022 انفجار في مركز للمسيرات تابعه للحرس
الثوري الايراني في مدينه كرمش غربي
البلاد واجهت ايران السابعه لاتهامي بشانه
الى اسرائيل حادثه اغتيال جديده في طهران
من العام الماضي هذه المره للعقيد حسن
صياد غذائي من قوات الحرس الثوري الايراني
لاسرائيل بالوقوف ورائها وبعد ايام حادث
في مركز للابحاث لوزاره الدفاع الايرانيه
في منطقه جنوب الشرقيه العاصمه طهران
ايران وصفته لعمليه بالتخريبيه واتهمت
اسرائيل بالوقوف وراها وفي نوفمبر 20
الثاني نقلت هيئه البث الاسرائيلي عن
مصادر قولها ان السلطات في جورجيا لخبطات
محاوله اغتيال الرجل اعمال اسرائيلي كانت
تخطط لها خليه ايرانيه كما اعلن جهاز
الموساد الاسرائيلي ان هو بالتعاون مع
اجهزه الامن التركيه جرى احباط محاوله
ايرانيه لاستهدف اسرائيليين في مدينه
اسطنبول في الشهور الماضيه وقبل ايام
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الايرانيه احضطه هجوم
بثلاث مسيرات استهدفت احد المصانع
العسكريه في مدينه اصفهان وسط البلد تصدت
لها المضادات الدفاعيه الايرانيه واقتصرت
الاضرار على سقف احد المصانع